اليوم سنتعرف على سلطه من نوع خاص بالنسبه
تحديدا للنساء انها سلطه الجاذبيه والجمال
الذي يحمل من الساحر ما يجعله قادرا على
التحكم ليس فقط بالمشاعر بل بالحياه ايضا
دراسه صينيه جديده نشرت في مجله محددات
علم النفس تقول ان الجاذبيه الجسديه
للمراه تزيد بشكل كبير قدرتها على
المساومه داخل المنزل الجمال يفرض القوه
هذا ما تفترضه الدراسه التي اراد مؤلفها
تاكيد ارتباط الجمال الجسدي للمراه
بالعلاقات الاجتماعيه لاسيما في المنزل
الدراسه اظهرت ان النساء الحاصلات على
درجه جاذبيه اعلى كان لهن دخل اعلى
وعلاقات افضل واحترام اعلى للذات مؤكده ان
الزوجات الجذابات قادرات على اتخاذ قرارات
رئيسيه في المنزل
هل بالفعل جمال المراه يؤثر على سلطتها في
المنزل العين تعشق كل جميل الجمال يعطي
المدخل يفتح الباب يفتح الابواب ولكن لا
يبقيك في المكان الجمال اللي مقصود فيه
هنا هو جمال الحضور وجمال الحضور مش بس
ملامح جمال الحضور عباره عن انسجام داخلي
الشخص يكون عنده حضور ناتج عن القوه
داخليه يعني الكلام اللي بيتكلم الافكار
المشاعر كلها منسجمه هذه الانسجام يظهر
جاذبيه لا تقاوم اضافه على جمال الملامح
اوكي طيب عبير هناك خط فاصل بين ان تكون
المراه مسيطره وبين ان تكون قويه بالمعنى
الايجابي ما هو هذا الخط
القويه انك تعرف تستخدم ادواتك بما ينفعك
وينفع الجميع السلطه انك تثبت موقفك وفقط
ماي واي لكن القوه الحقيقيه والسلطه
الحقيقيه انك انت موجود في من ضمن مجموعه
خصوصا لما نتكلم عن عائله او اسره موجود
من ضمن مجموعه فلما يكون عندي انا باور
معين معزز بجمال الحضور تكون السلطه
ايجابيه لمن انا استخدمها لفائده الجميع
في اتجاه صحيح طيب الدراسه تقول كذلك يا
عبير النساء المستقلات ماليا او الموظفات
او نساء اثريات يكون لديهن سلطه اقوى في
المنزل من هؤلاء الجميلات او الجذابات ما
رايك بذلك بالتاكيد لان الاستقلاليه
الماديه تعطيك ثقه انه انا مستقله بذاتي
او وجودي في هذا المنزل او وجودي في هذه
العائله هو اختيار اختيار انا يعني انا
اخترته بناء على رغبتي في ان انا اكون
موجوده في هذه الشراكه ليس اجبارا
غيابي عن هذا المكان او او غي عني لا يعني
ان انا راح احتاج لهم لكن انا موجوده
اختياريه فطبيعي هذا المشاعر تعطي الانسان
ثقه او تعطي المراه بالذات ثقه خصوصا في
ظل يعني خصوصا في ظل مجتمعات احنا يعني
احنا احنا تبرمجنا على كلمه كوني جميله
وصمتي او كوني جميله
كل شيء راح يجي لعندك الفكره غلط الفكره
ان عشان نشوف وحده جميله جميله وذكيه
وقويه تصير كانها معجزه طب هل يفضل الرجل
المراه الجذابه والمسيطره معا ان يكتفي
بالصفه الاولى
اتوقعي يفضل المراه الذكيه
[موسيقى]